[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to our very first sonic central
in honor of sonic's anniversary
it's hard to believe that it's been 30
years since sonic first appeared on the
scene
beginning as a video game character back
in the 16-bit console era to today
becoming an entertainment icon across
movies animation video games comics and
much much more
sonic and his friends continue to bring
joy to people around the world
and that means everything to us from
sonic and sega
to our longtime farm we say thank you
for being a part of sonic evolution over
the last 30 years
to our new friends we say welcome
in celebration of sonic 30th anniversary
we want to give you a sneak peek of a
lot of exciting content
that being worked on please keep in mind
that there is a lot more we will soon be
sharing
we hope you enjoy the premiere of sonic
central and be sure to stick around
till the end so sit back relax and enjoy
the show
it's not a celebration without music to
celebrate the sounds of sonic we are
excited to host a virtual symphony full
of your favorite tracks from throughout
the years
get ready to experience sonic melodies
like never before with a full symphony
orchestra including special performances
by the legendary sonic rock stars crush
40
composer and dj tamoya atani
and others mark your calendars and look
forward to enjoying this performance on
sonic's birthday june 23rd for
free from the comfort of your own home
be sure to tune
in to summer game fest for an exclusive
sneak peek
guess who's competing at the olympic
games this year it's none other than the
blue blur
sonic the hedgehog dress up your avatar
as sonic and compete in 18 fun-filled
olympic events
go for the gold your style in basketball
tennis football and much more
this is your chance to compete in this
year's olympics with your family and
friends
tokyo 2020 is coming to all platforms
june 22nd
and is available for pre-order today
next up is two point hospital the game
where you design
and manage a complex healthcare
institution and cure some very unusual
ailments
[Music]
sonic will be visiting patients in need
with exclusive sonic themed in-game
items and customization options
have some fun and swap your staff
outfits to your favorite characters
or add some swanky sonic decor to your
hospital
enjoy these free in-game items on july
30th
and bring your patients back to great
health and elegant sonic style and speed
this fall sonic the fighters will be
playable in lost judgment
lost judgment is a legal suspense
thriller from the creators of the yakuza
series
visit any sega arcade location in game
and experience the fun of a perfect
recreation of this 1996 fighting classic
sonic the fighters in lost judgment
arrives september 24th
stay tuned for more information on
future collaborations throughout the
year
[Music]
and now prepare for the ultimate sonic
ride
let's do it
ah
sonic colors ultimate will be speeding
in the store september 7th this year
be sure to pre-order online today to
receive the baby sonic keychain and more
in-game sonic movie content
stay tuned in the coming weeks to learn
more about sonic colors ultimate
and now let's hear from a very special
guest
hey hey everybody to celebrate the
release of
sonic colors ultimate we are so excited
to announce
sonic colors rise of the wisps now
taking place in the world of sonic
colors this two part animation is the
first of some short form animations
coming your way
that will feature full dialogue from the
sonic voice cast
in this you follow sonic and tales to
sweet mountain as they meet up with
their new friend the jade ghost wisp
to free all the captured wisps from the
evil dr eggman
and his robot henchmen and lucky you we
have a special treat a preview of
episode one happening right here right
now will our heroes prevail
find out when sonic colors rise of the
wisps debuts
this summer we will see you guys soon
with so much more good stuff but for now
you know the drill we gotta go
fast
it's okay sonic's gonna save he's a cake
buddy
[Music]
oh no let's get
how's it going metal you're looking
hideous as usual
we are also excited to announce we're
working on a new compilation for next
year that includes sonic 1
2 sonic 3 and knuckles and sonic cd
jump back in time and play these classic
sonic hits in sonic origins
experience the non-stop sonic action
like never before
this is your chance to experience the
beginnings of sonic on the latest
platforms
now with added content and features stay
tuned for more information
later in the year
this year we're taking sonic to new
heights and expanding
sonic mania and team sonic racing are
now available on amazon
luna
also on june 1st sonic forces team sonic
racing and sonic mania are coming to
playstation now
we've also got some special events for
you in the sonic mobile world
starting in may and sonic dash sail into
a special pirate themed party
be among the first to unlock pirate
sonic and captain shadow
and win other great prizes by collecting
all four birthday themed items on the
track
this summer in sonic forces a very
special character will be dropping into
action
harness the power of the chaos emeralds
and blast into battle as supersonic
fly down the track at fantastic speeds
and smash through your opponent's
attacks
in this invincible super form later this
year get ready to battle your friends in
some private races
this limited time event will allow you
to set up your own exclusive matches
with friends
enjoy the rush of sonic forces in this
fun party mode
this october prepare yourself for a
fright as the werehog bounds into sonic
forces and sonic dash
look out for his arrival around
halloween and unleash your power
and lastly in sonic racing on apple
arcade
we are going classic race as a classic
character
in a classic car and on three new tracks
in a classic zone
all while listening to some brand new
music
now let's check in with the showrunners
of the recently announced animated
series
sonic prime coming to netflix in 2022
hi i'm joe kelly for man of action
entertainment and one of the show
runners on the upcoming netflix animated
series
sonic prime man of action is a writer's
collective
consisting of myself joe casey stephen c
siegel and duncan roulette
we created a couple of things you might
have heard of the ben 10 franchise for
cartoon network
the heroes and team of big hero 6 for
disney
and a bunch of other shows that we've
worked on over the years in animation
been kind of busy we are very excited
to be working with sega and sonic on
this project
during sonic's 30th anniversary and this
is a dream project for us
we've been working really hard to bring
fans something that they've never seen
before
in a sonic series we'll be bringing our
experience and passion for the brand
with us on sonic prime
to deliver a fun and exciting series for
sonic fans of all ages
over the course of 24 episodes sonic
will be thrust into a high-speed
adventure
through the strange and mysterious
shatter bursts it's up to sonic
to save the universe and along the way
experience moments of self-discovery
and redemption sonic prime is set to
premiere worldwide
in 2022 we look forward to taking this
journey with you
and sharing more information with you at
a later date
things like this
thanks again i'll be seeing you in the
shadow purse
this year we're also making a variety of
exciting 30th anniversary themed
products
take home the epic battle straight from
sonic 2 with the giant eggman robot
playset from jakks pacific
for the fans dialed into hip hop culture
comes the sonic the hedgehog 30th
anniversary jewelry collaboration with
king ice
you can also revisit 30 years of sonic
games with the comprehensive 30th
anniversary in cyclo speedia from dark
horse
for sonic memorabilia we have an
exclusive collection of coins in silver
and gold from app max
head to the official sonic 30th
anniversary site for more information on
all of our commemorative products
well there you have it as you can see
we've been working hard behind the
scenes to prepare great things for you
there will be a lot of announcements
throughout the year so be sure to follow
us on official social channels linked in
the video description below
so thank you for celebrating with us and
being there every step of the way
here's to the next 30 years of signing
hold on i don't think we are done yet
i have one more thing i'd like to show
the fan all right azuka-san
let's see it
[Music]
you